just as in World War II today patriotic
American workers are building the
Arsenal democracy and serving the cause
of
Freedom this is a pivotal time for the
United States and what helped get us
here is the shameful appeasement of Iran
not just by Biden but by Obama as well
joining me now is Victor Davis Hansen
senior fellow at the Hoover institution
Victor thanks for being with us everyone
remembers the wooden pallets stacked
with cash that Obama sent to Iran along
with the love letters but where El what
else got us here and are we in a
pre-World War II
moment well it depends uh I think the
enemies of the United States and Israel
think we are but it depends on our
deterrence we've got two huge aircraft
carriers that are going to be in the
Eastern Mediterranean we've got the
Israelis poised to demolish Hamas and
I'm kind of counterintuitive about that
judge if we are allowing the Israeli to
destroy Hamas I don't think Hezbollah
will intervene if they don't destroy it
or they feel they seem to be weak I
think Hezbollah will pile on the same
goes true with our Fleet if they
tolerate No No not one rocket pointed at
them if the president demands that if
they kill one American in Gaza they're
going to pay for it then I think it we
won't we'll avoid a war but if you
continue to mify them I think they're
going to consider that weakness to be
exploited and not magnam minity to be
reciprocated and you know I don't think
we've really appeased Iran I think it's
a little bit worse than that under the
Obama Administration and the
continuation of the Biden Administration
it's they see it as a strategic
partnership Kerrie was meeting with Mr
zarif the foreign minister all during
the Trump Administration on several
occasions and uh King Abdullah of the
late King Abdullah you remember he he
suggested to us that we might have to
Boman he was so exasperated and Leon
Panetta said I don't think you got and
he was in the the Obama Administration
said I don't think you're serious about
stopping this Iran Iranian nuclear
program so they really thought that they
could partner with uh with Iran and
create an oppositional block to the
Saudis the gulf monarchies Israel and
and have creative tension and then they
would adjudicated as if there was more
no moral difference between a Humane and
con
constitutional Israel and a Theocratic
bloodthirsty and Terror supporting Iran
and that's that's why we're in this fix
right now a lot of those people judge
are still in the Biden Administration
and they still believe that they can
partner with Iran uh and create some
kind of new paradigm in the Middle East
Victor you know Biden was just asked
moments ago will Israel delay the ground
Invasion until you can pull the hostages
out his answer yes you're
reaction well he's he doesn't really
understand any that, 1400 people were
murdered yes and mutilated and
desecrated and when he keeps telling
them you restrain you restrain you
restrain does he have any credibility
not when he gives a hundred million
dollar to the to Hamas and you know
Anthony blinkin even though he knew that
story was questionable and then
ultimately false about the hospital was
telling our embassies in the Middle East
to lower the flag to half M and that
showed weakness it showed that we were
paranoid and then Joe Biden said well
the problem was they didn't shoot
straight Islamic Jihad and what does
that mean that had they shoot straight
had they shot straight and killed Jews
we wouldn't be in this fix of of
demonstration and having to mify or
appease the Middle East so what's coming
out of the White House Is Not Just
counterproductive it's bizarre it's
really surreal judge it it is and even
with this Jack l
who was part one of the architects of
the uh the Iran nuclear deal they want
him to be the ambassador to Israel
Victor yeah I know I think they're
saying to Iran we want to enter back
into this strategic partnership and we
want to do it so much that we're willing
to offend the Israelis both their
sensibilities and practical reality
we're going to put an Iran deal promoter
right in them in a time when they've
suffered 1,400 casualties horrible Cas
that should be that should show you how
much uh we're interested in restoring
what Barack Obama had created all right
Victor thanks hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else